so now it's time for revenge for the
world champion yeah last time in the air
things masters we actually saw uh magnus
again with white there he opened with
his king's pawn one e4 he's got away
from that and now he's opened with the
english opening uh eric deciding upon
what to play and just occupying the
center with the pawn this is what we
call the four knights of variation and
magnus just
again pushing a pawn to fiance his
bishop in the entrance into the position
yeah
and oh one of them's moved okay
unfortunately
we do see a trade of horns and uh now
after this white's gonna castle black's
gonna get his bishop out he's gonna do
the same and
um yeah we call this the reverse dragon
not sure why it's called the dragon
maybe because it breathes fire but
um either way this is still well known
theoretically so uh yeah he's just
hoping to outplay eric so i'm this is
the opening that i'm gonna study i love
it already super cool i used to play
this yeah avoid all this computer
preparation so everything that you know
had been said before he picks up little
tips here and there he knows how to put
psychological pressure on his opponents
and
okay i mean well getting back to this
game it has differed from that carlson
against kramnik game that i mentioned
earlier but white has started pushing
pawns trying to gain space on the queen
side on this left side of the board
black just organizing his pieces it
looks like black's been retreating a bit
especially the black dark squad bishop
going back next to his king but this is
very common type of technique and now
magnus jumped forward with the white
bishop attacking the white uh attacking
the black queen uh we saw that blocked
and this is still very thematic both
players clearly have studied something
similar to this before as most of you
probably know and a move two moves yeah
wow really committal as well from magnus
carlsen so he's traded off white's dark
squared bishop which tends to be quite a
good piece actually in these positions
he's traded off for a night but look at
black's pawns over there on the b file
black has two double pawns over there
and magnus is gonna hope he's gonna play
the long game he's gonna hope that's a
strategic weakness later on but black
does have the bishop pair so this is
really really uh complex now i'm not
sure who i prefer in these types of
positions
uh white has a great light square bishop
to compensate for uh maybe his lack of
fight on the dark squares later on but
then again black can get organized if
black can get all his pieces off the
back rank at some point then eric will
be happy you know also sometimes
traveling to for chess events so but
streaming yes it's it's cool and we all
know that uh eric hansen is a really
popular and good streamer these days
meanwhile we've seen a huge move by
magnus carson because he's sacrificed to
pawn and it's not 100 clear what his
plan is if eric
doesn't trust him and takes it but okay
eric did not call the bluff uh magnus i
think he had a special idea up his
sleeve and whether he uh just trusted
magnus and uh didn't even want to
calculate didn't even want to waste time
working out the consequences there
instead he brought his rook across and
white's knight has indeed jumped okay
the bishop has indeed come out to cover
the light squares around the black king
that's a good start
so it's all about the bishops and
whether white can prove these are
weaknesses magnus is going for them he's
brought his knight to the side of the
board
double attack now against this pawn and
it's just a really complex positional
strategic fight eric dropping back with
his knight he's counter-attacking
against the white pawns now eric i've
nev never seen him play this fast i must
admit this is a clear strategy from him
i'm going to learn my lesson and i'm
going to play as confidently as i can
yeah it must have been a confidence
boost for him to do so well in the last
tournament to beating magnus and getting
through to the knockouts
okay meanwhile a set of pawns have been
exchanged on this left side of the board
on the queen side okay she has done this
attacking the black knight and the pawn
next to it
so it's become a bit more concrete it is
about calculation now and the stakes are
higher than ever
she finds the best move though
so that's yeah i mean that's mightily
impressive he paused at the right moment
and the whole idea is if white's queen
went up and grabbed a pawn black's queen
would have been able to come down and
take a pawn as well so white's queen was
forced to retreat and now the black
knight also stepping back but the black
knight it's done a bit of a dance it's
found it's safe uh it's found itself on
a safe square just offering some
exchanges okay white has an advantage
here according to the evaluation bar but
it's not easy at least for magnus now
he's defending his knights with his
rooks all of the pieces entering the
action and okay
surprised by eric hansen just taking the
time out to shuffle his king to the
corner maybe he'd seen this position in
advance actually when he was having that
longer think a few moves ago even this
one
likes to remind me and it okay magnus i
joked about it but he's played the move
that we've seen already in every game
today he's played h4 picked up this pawn
and
he's given his king some breathing space
instructive but also just hinting to
eric that this pawn might destabilize
the black position uh that's one skill
that the top players really have yeah
it's really hard to to have such a skill
just to stay
peaceful and don't make your position
worse than it is now just something for
eric
the psychology of chess i know and i
also it's also this poor move doesn't
come with too much risk because look at
that chain of pawns
magnus maybe he has to take a time out
with the white bishop okay he puts it in
the center of the board that is
provocative i thought he maybe would
drop it back next to his king keep it
safe
but now what happens if eric pushes a
pawn to kick that bishop away that's a
good question
he plays really actively to push this
pawn forward he actually gave up a move
earlier to let eric put the push the f
pawn forward for free now he's trying to
do it again but eric pushes this pawn
eric's last move a pawn push weakening
and just a bit too slow
he needed to be a bit more concrete a
bit more aggressive maybe attacking the
opponent's bishop and magnus okay
meanwhile bring his queen to the side of
the board it has been there already yeah
surprising it's been there already as
you mentioned
it was here five six moves ago and at
least he's going for a pawn uh really
surprising i think eric now has to push
this pawn forward otherwise he's just
too passive he's too late half a point
as soon as they had scored a half point
then the 1800 would lose it would win
do you think that's possible was that
really interesting excitement is
guaranteed in this one i think all right
a draw still far far um
well it's the most unlikely result i
reckon here
okay trader bishops and it's that strong
knight in the middle of the ward against
that black bishop which doesn't look
good right now but could come to life
later yeah i think it was heating up a
bit too much for magnus carlsen's liking
so he's trying to get the queens off
he's trying to head for his favorite end
game
and uh yeah the white queen's sliding
across defending her knight defending
her rook if the black queen trades white
would recapture and i still think white
has the better chances because white's
minor piece is better the knight
superior to the bishop magnus has to
find something else but look at the
clock times as well one minute okay he
does go for that move i feel maybe the
safest move in the position bringing his
knight to the side
and hitting this black rook this is what
happens to anybody i think but one i
think tip for our spectators for our
followers that it's good to finish the
game and only after that to start
thinking what did you do wrong yeah
exactly and we always see the players
analyze the games as soon as they finish
but during the games especially someone
like magnus he's good at just forgetting
and just living in the moment yeah so
yeah
it's the only moment when it's good to
forget things actually right
just forget everything until the game is
over yeah okay meanwhile the position we
actually predicted did arise the queens
got exchanged black rook came to the
fifth rank actually defending everything
black's bishop also um
protecting that rook and magnus just
teaming up his rooks together and eric
now has a choice does he trade those
rooks again he's got to decide whether
it's on his terms he does
allowing white to look into the game i
felt that was a bit too accommodating
actually because the only white benefit
benefited from that trade i think it
would have been much better to activate
the other rookie yep
and now black's bishop does have an
opportunity to go and take that pawn it
has happened we highlighted that pawn as
a weakness but black's pawn falls as
well so still level material but double
attack white's rook hitting the bishop
of course first but also the pawn the
black pawn in the center of the board
time trouble and that's when mistakes
happen and already we see the evaluation
bar shoot off to white side black's
bishop now is passive it's gone to a bad
square don't necessarily defend each
other and magnus going after black's b
pawn
okay we're actually going to see a
similar scenario to the game between zhu
and june and latinx black has given up a
pawn but he's going to try and seek
solace in a rook end game you have to
get rid of that white knight over the
next couple of moves that white knight
cannot be allowed to survive because
then it will help white extra sea pawn
forward his rook can perhaps cut off the
black king
and i think eric is choosing a different
he's maybe choosing to keep the rook i
mean take the rooks off and keep the
minor pieces on which i'm not sure about
actually okay this is all about timing
because if black's king can get across
fast enough the white knight is almost
trapped and the black king can even go
for white's extra pawn the white extra
pawn blockaded by black's bishop
but if the white knight is able to
destabilize that black bishop if the
white king can get in if the white pawn
can push it's just going to be game over
so it can relocate itself to i was going
to say the c6 square and get out via the
a-line but he's chosen a different way
so now he choose to move his king but
otherwise c5 would probably lose a pawn
yeah
okay so white didn't take the risk of
pushing the extra pawn forward because
it might become weak as you mentioned
instead trying to activate the white
king but now i'm expecting eric to lock
things down there we go and the pawn
structure on the king side now actually
maybe favors black suddenly it feels to
me like eric's made some progress and
magnus hasn't really magnus has lost a
lot of time with his knight
looking up at the c4 pawn so this is why
magnus plays
a crafty move you know puts his knight
on the edge of the board he says no
you're not going to go for that plan
but it's not the most active night i've
ever seen white's knight is definitely
not in the most centralized not the most
happy uh but white's king
is slowly going to snake its way over to
support the white knight maybe
retreating
and there we go both kings doing a bit
of a dance push his h pawn forward two
squares blockade on the light squares
and they use his bishop to trade pawns
and behind and look at all of white's
pawns they're just right for the picking
all of these pawns on dart squares if
the bishop does get behind it's just
gonna be if anything winning for black
so white's king now has had to step back
but if the bishop just leaves itself on
the side of the board on this diagonal
hinting it later coming in then the
white king has to stay guarding this
square the bishop dominating the white
knight let's go back to the players we
might see a result if eric can maybe
hold his nerve and also make sure he
plays quickly enough yes he plays with
10 seconds all the time
as i was talking i looked at the clock
and
slightly panicked
10 seconds or 15 seconds yeah every time
eric moves now i don't know why he uses
so much time he just needs to make a
good bishop move and he has a whole
board to make them so okay so he's just
centralizing the bishop okay so magnus
he's been sneaky you know he's saying
well maybe i'm going to do something
with my king on the right side you push
a pawn forward and eric says no he's not
going to go for that
lock it down really nice strategy just
pawns on the opposite color of your
bishop the black bishop controls the
dark squares the pawns control the light
squares uh just one to remember at home
and the king coming back where he came
from
he had found no joy on this side of the
board uh magnus has all the time in the
world
eric doesn't have all the time in the
world two seconds
but uh yeah unfortunately still nothing
for eric
sorry no way for magnus come through and
not much to do for eric either he can
just sit and wait and there we go the
bishop just kind of yo-yoing back and
forth between this square the center
and
magnus can't really break through if he
starts pushing pawns for example white
can push the f-pawn forward he only
creates more weaknesses in his own camp
and magnus has to maintain this kind of
blockade this type of fortress with the
white knight and pawn and i think is
just going to shuffle the bishop between
those two squares and no but magnus is
going for it he's making a pawn break
yeah
so he notices that his opponent is
playing not so fast let's say and only
with seconds on his clock so maybe he
will be able to surprise his opponent at
a certain point and then he can have
chances
yeah and okay a trade of pawns
magnus making a bit of a face though now
black's bishop can come to the center of
the board white's knight actually has no
squares at all
i think his plan is to trade also g bomb
yeah so magnus has only one plan he's
got to push his pawns forward trades are
good for the weak side right yeah
let's exchange all the boats and then
we're fine holds the white king at bay
so for instance here you don't take
pawns and invite the king to step to the
fourth row you just hold the tension
what is eric going to do
what is magnus going to do sorry magnus
magnus has nothing to do
he just has to wait
but then again okay i'm shocked by the
evaluation bar what is the idea behind
this one he's blocked things up
completely now eric has to just wait can
white somehow get the king back into the
game remember white's knight has no safe
squares you can't push your extra pawn
either
forward because then the black king
comes towards the white knight
okay the white king tries to get in it's
denied that's the check it's kicked back
oh i know it's gonna step back and as
you mentioned black central pawn is
actually isolated now trying to force
eric and down under 10 seconds again
should he try to go for something else
and so he's gone for the king
move okay
wow okay so white might continue with
the plan but white tonight also has the
opportunity at some point now to try and
jump out of its cage from uh on the edge
of the board
it can jump forward i don't think that
really helps at the moment
uh that's the first move i would
calculate actually you know because it's
a consequence of black's last movie okay
he does it jump in with a knight and if
that knight starts
attacking some pawns on the right
they're going to fall actually maybe
magnus has a route to try and win black
central pawn i was worried here about
black's king stepping forward in front
of white's extra pawn oh there we go and
now white's knight can actually give a
check
um i don't think you want to go to any
other square you might get trapped or it
can step back actually wait it's
stepping towards the black cheap one
maybe magnus is winning suddenly yeah
wow we've seen a turn around wow eric
has just let the white knight back into
the game
i played that move with less than one
second left
and he's losing his pawns those pawns
now the jeep black g6 point it's fallen
yeah and those pawns are way more
important than the pawns on the other
side of the board black's kings and just
not participating now it's in no man's
land and uh now he's got the best type
of pawn it's a protect it's a past porn
and the bishop he will win the bishop
wow we talked about squeezing water out
of the stone that has happened in this
game it was just a dead draw eric had it
almost within its uh within his grasp
and here we go black bishop has to stop
the white pawn but after this capture
that white pawn is going to cost black
his bishop and eric resigns magnus
squeezed out the win oh wow both players
shaking their heads a little bit of a
payback for magnus calls